y por supuesto que hablamos de economía
en directo américa ya está comido en el
estudio daniela brandon daniela feliz
viernes se feliz de fin de semana ya
para nosotros que nos vamos a alcanzar
dentro de poco hoy es un día clave para
la economía venezolana que más le va a
pasar a la economía venezolana daniela
muchas cosas pasan día a día en la
economía venezolana raúl usted y yo lo
sabemos pues mire entra en vigencia este
viernes la tercera reconversión
monetaria en el país la tercera en 13
años y como se explica una reconversión
monetaria pues se le quitan ceros a la
divisa nacional dejemos que sean
herminia fernández y nicole coasters
quienes nos expliquen de qué se trata
teórico rubio comerciante informal se
muestra escéptico ante la tercera
reconversión monetaria que entra en
vigor en venezuela a partir del primero
de octubre cree que la medida no
solucionará el problema de fondo una
inflación que supera el 1700 por ciento
y que han generado la escasez de
billetes en la última década bueno
supuestamente eso no va a solucionar
nada digamos
con la parte económica dios quiera que
su vengáis para movilizar y administrar
todos supuestamente lo están haciendo lo
que escuche se lo están haciendo para la
broma de contabilidad a ilesa la parte
bancaria
la parte económica de gama de negocios
que yo pueda trabajar el nuevo cono
monetario es decir el nuevo circulante
tendrá seis ceros menos y se llamará
bolívar digital los analistas sostienen
que la decisión es sólo un paño de agua
caliente entonces la reconversión si es
una nueva una solución es un alivio pero
la verdadera el verdadero problema es
acabar con la inflación volver a sacar
las moneda adaptar los sistemas esos son
costos que se reflejan en última
instancia también en la inflación y en
la economía en general
sin embargo algunos venezolanos esperan
resultados positivos
espero que sea para bien
existen ahora
económico del trabajo del 7 es un pueblo
de mejor manera
y que ayuden a poder adquisitivo
risa un señor que yo lo creo innecesario
con el bautizado bolívar digital el
gobierno también quiere impulsar aún más
las transacciones virtuales mecanismo
que se aceleró por la falta del papel
moneda y que se ha vuelto la forma común
de pago en el país
la novedad real de la reconversión será
que los venezolanos van a tener por un
tiempo dinero efectivo en sus manos
qué tanto va a servir además daniela
porque es una economía totalmente
dolarizada
cambiamos ahora información porque el
congreso de eeuu evitó el cierre
administrativo de gobierno finalmente lo
olvidaron no claro y después de una
votación a contrarreloj porque el plazo
se vencía el jueves en la a la
medianoche pues hoy el país amanece con
un nuevo presupuesto nacional por lo
menos hasta el 3 de diciembre ahora la
siguiente batalla para los demócratas es
el aumento del límite de endeudamiento
del país del que también hemos hablado
los republicanos no lo quieren apoyar
con esto
es imperativo que el congreso aborde el
límite de la deuda de lo contrario
nuestra estimación actual es que el
tesoro probablemente agotará sus medidas
extraordinarias para el 18 de octubre en
ese momento el tesoro se quedará con
recursos muy limitados que se agotarán
rápidamente
eeuu dejaría de pagar por primera vez en
la historia y en reino unido el break
city causando sus estragos ya lo estamos
viendo de hecho la crisis de camioneros
de gente que maneja estas camiones para
el combustible ahora las casas de
carniceros claro llevamos más de una
semana con esta crisis de combustibles
pero es que la falta de personal no es
solamente de camioneros es de todo el
personal en general raúl y es que pues
el gobierno de boris johnson reconoció
que el problema de la falta de
conductores puede tardar una semana más
al menos pero ahora se suma esta otra
dificultad no hay personal suficiente en
las plantas de productos navideños como
pavos y jamón es grave la asociación
británica de procesadores de carnes dijo
al diario the times
hay un déficit de al menos 15.000
carniceros la asociación nacional del
cerdo fue más allá aseguró que por falta
de personal hay miles de cerdos que no
se han podido matar y no hay sitio para
mantenerlos así que no descarta un
sacrificio masivo de animales usted que
es vegetariano menor porque desgraciada
ni la verdad ojalá que puedan resolver
esto porque además lo que sufren son los
animalitos danielle indicadores bueno
las bolsas asiáticas se contagiaron de
wall street que tuvo una pésima jornada
el jueves la bolsa de tokio cerró por
ejemplo con una caída de más del 2 por
ciento y en australia pasó lo mismo por
su parte las bolsas europeas están
también a la baja todo debido al
problema también de la inflación que
está muy alta daniela imdb la cifra el
día para nuestro segundo bloque
económico de directo américa de viernes
me parece claro que sí vamos a ver ahora
nuestro reportaje del día